their point that you thought you weren't
gonna do another album I get took a big
break but was there pointed no I don't
think I ever thought about not ever
doing another album when and what that
album would be like and you know where I
was I was gonna come about right for it
right in the songs that those things
were questions on that well we now know
what that album will sound like because
Sam hunt has released his second album
five and a half years after his debut
and it's called suicide
now why call it suicide it's just I
don't know sort of a stream of
consciousness way I said I started just
writing down titles and I just write
wrote a list of just the things that
just thought about the record thought
about the music thought about where I'm
from people who've influenced my songs
music as simple as my songs and all
these things I just start right now
worse and this songs been Southside just
kept standing out is that I have a lyric
and Buddy like a back road the first
line of the song says got a girl yeah
but uh South Side's always didn't kind
of know we're from the South Side's
person from the south side let's get
just some of these reviews first so
Entertainment Weekly gives you the B+
writing Sam hunt showcases this a little
charm on Southside now they say the one
misstep is that ain't beautiful and I
actually like that song to each his own
now sounds like Nashville really liked
it they wrote Sam hunt pulls back the
curtain on the person underneath the
artist on his new album so side the
modern trailblazer feels revitalized on
Southside moving the ticker forward
enough to indicate that he has evolved
while solidifying his ability to
establish a distinct sound and lyrical
prowess that continues to captivate the
country audience now slant did not like
it
they gave it two to five stars writing
Sam hunt suicide is a shallow attempt
genre pastiche now I don't agree with
that one but it is interesting listening
to this album because once you check out
the track listing you realize that this
music spans over the last three years
because by like a back road is on here
that's in 2017 it's always drinking too
much
and then downtown stead is 2018 so
there's three songs already that are
over two years old and then we heard
three of these songs leading up to the
release of this album which is normal
for an album like we heard kinfolks
hard to forget and sitting with you so
that's already six of the songs we
already know and this is a 12 track
album so it's a little bit interesting
getting your head around that because we
originally heard these six songs
individually over a long period of time
now they're being packaged together as
this album so now it's like okay how do
these work in terms terms of a concept
of an album so yeah I'm still wrapping
my head around that I will say the
strongest strongest element to this
album is starting the album off with
2016 listening to that song wrath that
it completely kind of threw me off being
like whoa what's going on here cuz this
type of song would be something you
closed off an album with because it's so
introspective it's so emotional and it's
so simple in a way that that would be
something you closed off in a bit really
usually with at the beginning of them
you really want to start things off on a
big huge note but this ends up being a
big couch note because it really lets
you know how Sam is approaching this is
talking about how much he screwed up in
2016 in terms of his personal life how
many wrong choices he made and of course
yeah now we've just seen him grow and
now he's finally back with new music
he's comfortable that he wants to put an
album out so you know what the journey
has been like for him so even though
he's talking about his love life that's
really talking about his journey as a
whole so you really understand where
he's coming into this as and you really
get a great perspective on it so I just
thought that was a perfect way to open
it I love that song but of course he
gets back into this the the normal stuff
that we love from the Sam hunt and and
that always has that country hip-hop mix
to it so there's really really fun stuff
here and yeah I think I do still need to
get into this album as a whole because
we heard six of these songs right I've
already listened to it once all the way
through but I think this is a very solid
album that I can't wait to hear what you
guys have to think about it